editor-at-large at the Daily Mail
compeers Morgana's didn't we once
compete against each other when we like
enemies or not where we're always fine
good to see you sir is great to be back
in the show know me you were always you
were always charming in victory I have
to say this charming nothing I would it
was never personal there's a hundred
thousand other channels I'm trying to
compete against all of them you say
Muller's team is panicking and fishing I
agree with you I don't think they have
ever found anything related to collusion
and they just keep springing off into
these other well he fired Comey he has
an absolute right to fire James Comey
and it's actually scary in terms of what
I believe is a fishing expedition and I
think you agree with that I do and
actually I'm not finding extraordinary
that James Comey a former boss of the
FBI is able to write a sort of tell-all
book right in the middle of the mother
investigation I mean this wouldn't this
wouldn't happen in many other countries
Shawn that you wouldn't be allowed to do
this
peddling all sorts of lurid and
ridiculous details to the world and it
makes me think this Donald Trump fired
it because he didn't trust him right
well he was right wasn't he when you
read the stuff that's pouring out of his
book Donald Trump was absolutely right
not to trust James Comey in in relation
to the wider lunar probe I just think
what's happening here is that they tried
to get the proof on Russian collusion
they want to prove to the world that
Donald Trump collaborated with Russians
to fix the election that's why he won no
other reason has to be that and so far
they have singularly failed to establish
that so now they're moving the goalposts
now they're moving to stuff about his
private life with lead allegations
involving women going back more than
10-15 years two things about this Sean I
don't think people care about Donald
Trump's ex-wife I don't think it's on
the same scale of misdemeanor even if it
happened to what we saw happen with a
Democratic President Bill Clinton who
let's not remind ourselves had sexual
relations with a young intern in the
Oval Office
while he was president but thirdly I
don't think the voters care I don't
think people are out there going Wow can
you believe Donald Trump may have had a
few flings 10 15 years ago so to me
they're now going after him purely to
embarrass him purely to try and diminish
him to degrade him as president and I
think that this is because they are a
years to get the Russia collision lines
a stick so NBC News supposed to be you
know trusted news organizations they're
actually saying tonight that Robert
Muller is going to report on at least
four findings of Trump and obstruction
of justice here's what it is one the
intend to fire Muller not that he fired
him and he had a thought it's like oh
okay we're gonna punish his thought the
second one is oh did he craft a
statement about the meeting in Trump
Tower have anything to say did he talk
of pardoning witnesses the power of
pardon as you know piers is absolute for
a US president and fourth pressuring
Jeff Sessions not to recuse himself I
didn't have time because Jeff Sessions
didn't tell him he was recusing himself
and it recused themselves the day after
he was confirmed so I'm listening to
this is what represents news you live in
great but I love tabloid news I really
you guys are great at it we have pretty
good tabloid news at New York this is
such garbage and yet I think it is shown
yeah yeah it is and and what you just
played there from Joy Behar let's just
remind ourselves what she has just said
on a mainstream show to America she has
actually said that Donald Trump is
somehow worse than Kim jong-un or
Vladimir Putin like Kim jong-un is one
of the world's worst if not the worst
dictator a man who has repressed his
people beyond any scale that we have
seen in modern times he starves them he
beats em he torches them he poisons them
he kills them recently we had an
American student who was tortured and
later died after being held in in
terrible captivity for nearly two years
because he took a poster off a wall
that's the kind of person that you're
talking about with Kim jong-un a man
well along with his father for three
decades has threatened to destroy
unbelievable at every chance he can
always compare we're supposed to believe
that the president United States is
worse I think it's ridiculous and call
me comparing the president to one of the
most infamous murderers of all time
Sammy the ball
all right piers great to see you thank
you for being with us